the couple leaving right now is Heather
and Max okay nobody can believe that
happen I mean a professional dancer and
partner max jaws dropped Monday night
when Heather Morris and max got the boot
on Dancing with the Stars and there is
no doubt that Heather was one of the
best dancers so what went wrong while
camera matheson is uncovering what it
really takes to win the Mirrorball
trophy the show is based so heavily on
fan boats they just lacked that I guess
when it comes to who stays and who goes
fifty percent of the decision comes from
viewers vote the other half it's only
how the judges rate the performances so
strategy number one you know what they
want they're all looking for different
things at the end of the day Len is
always looking for that technique it was
madness on the floor there was no
control Carrie Anne is looking for those
lifts just Carrie and specifically no
lips in a ballroom dance there yah is
the number one concern she yeah yes I
did dock a point for the lift but I
still know Bruno is looking for the
personality like a tornado ha ha ha
the thing that I really can't stand
people that don't put their passion
emotion go wrong but do it with passion
strategy number two know your partner's
abilities when choreographing your dance
the choreography was amazing pita stop
you have a routine you have an idea of
what you want when you walk in the room
but you can't get married to the steps
because if that doesn't look good on
them you have to find another option and
then there's that hard to define quality
called chemistry Julianne really likes I
think the connection between the couple
do you feel that yeah we all do at
another strategy if you want those
viewer vote when you perform is just as
important as how you perform do you
think that order affects the way people
vote absolutely really for sure you want
to be closer to the end of the show so
you're one of the last things that
people see and finally when it comes to
that last and those viewer votes are all
that really matter because the judges
scores don't count the final freestyle
dance
usually the
one that gets the public they just get
on the phone that's what gets you the
Mirrorball
[Music]